my face because there is a case that no
one will see my face behind the mask so
yeah
in the program i have a large name a
manual basically takes care of this a
typical problem that i have my my real
name is manolis and my research interest
lies in the intersection of theoretical
computer science game theory machine
learning and optimization
actually
just because we're in meeting conference
i decided to say who am i so i was born
in athens i did my undergrad studies
in the only school that we're doing that
stuff in ntua and right now i'm
graduating from columbia university
i can say that my dissertation is about
noise in total search problems but i
decided a little bit to start with
[Music]
a story i know that we have heard lots
of stories today and i want to do
something more relaxing so i have a
question for you do you believe that
this is a real polyhedron uh hands
quickly do you believe that it's real
yes or no
oh yeah i have one all the other believe
that it is not real
okay
so
in geometry uh
johnson and norman johnson in 1966
proposed the following
construction he said okay i will call a
joseon polyhedron to be a strictly
complex polyhedron where each phase
would include only regular polygons and
actually he present at least where of 92
polygons
and 92 polyhedrons that they
they cover this assumption plus
all the ancient mathematician prisms
that they cover also that assumption
now
again i will ask that question is that
the polyhedron a real
polyhedron a real conversation here it
seems so right
so
the answer is no
three years later a soviet using
a mathematician serg
proved that
the list of
of johnson with the 92
polygons was complete
so
that means that this structure
cannot exist which does not make sense
because the photo is real
so something is happening
and of course the reality is that uh
just to to explain my motivation here is
the reality is that the theory speak
always about worst case analysis the
worst case analysis here is that we have
perfect uh
perfect guarantee for example about the
measurements but if i ask you and i
challenge that with probability one if
you go at home and you do that
experiment you will achieve with
probability one to construct the polygon
for example with hexagons and pentagons
that it is forbidden by a circular proof
and the reason is the the near misses
that we have in the measurements so this
is my my question in my research so that
is the way that i started working in
local optimization and actually my first
work was about the smooth complexity a
way to go beyond the worst case analysis
typically for the majority problems that
we have in local optimization they are
np hardware less complete
exponential work guarantees
so no one would like to solve them but
uh
there are prominent solutions that they
are actually local heuristics and there
are ways in theory to prove that they
are really good enough actually if you
think about it
in the previous century we're applying
uh from the previous century until now
we're applying just one algorithm it's a
local sets method and we call it
gradient descent and the in
like this is my first paper i think as a
phd we proved that even without
gradients if the stuff are really smooth
you can
avoid certain points and have some good
local solution
but if we ask ourselves
nowadays i think in bootcamp of learning
games we establish it really nicely with
many different ways that
optimization is not something so simple
for example we have to
to get into data that they are shared in
multiple
different
servers we have to do some federated
situation where we want to learn
different stuff from different
learners and
like the bots in the warehouses have to
connect each other very very locally so
actually yeah this is uh the whole point
of my research that
that is what we are doing today that is
that hopefully we will do in the future
and yes i think that
it is ubiquitous that james
exists totally in optimization in many
different fields
so
yeah
in the majority of the problems that i
have worked was about the min max
optimization and especially how we use
them for
typical tricks that we have for the
generative adversarial networks
where
i try to prove again like what i said i
want to make
i'm trying to meet you i'm i'm trying to
to to
[Music]
to say what i am interested in and this
is what i am interested in to understand
mathematically what are the phenomena
that i see so
if i see the cycles i want to be able to
prove the cycles this is one of
these two works aim exactly on that to
understand different kind of models of
non-convex non-concave optimization that
they are applied in practice like in
guns
to prove that we have such kind of
phenomena
and after that we started to discuss
about the multi-agents i think and when
players are playing stuff like no regret
dynamics that many other speakers had
discussed today so i avoid
the
definitions and i just passed to the
main message so the main message that
we had in my in our research i think
that you can see it very clearly in that
picture that typically if you follow and
no regret dynamics this is the total
this is a totally rational assumption
what we have is
a convergence to strict equilibria but
for a mixed nash equilibrium the only
thing that we can do is to discover the
phase of the equilibrium but what we
cannot do is really to converge to that
point
now i will hear the
i will hear the correct
note that look we had the invented some
machinery to converge to that points
with different dynamics but all of them
again breaks
when and this is also in some of our
results if you put some stop plasticity
inside so all of these models if the
payoff that you are getting has again
some noise uh they have this kind of uh
all of them i mean this is a bad word
the totality shouldn't be a word of a
scientist but you understand my meaning
the majority of them they will behave
like that
so uh just to follow now the
um abstract that they gave uh something
that had the uh made me really
interested nowadays is what uh the model
that we present with johannes manages in
february
this is really inspired by what is
happening in practice uh
we call them uh
there is a
there there is actually a long
literature in that problem it is one
problem that i would like to work in
simon's
and we call them team games so a
two-team game is the following you you
have your players you separate them into
different teams
and
where you
ever play every player has some actions
and now how we will make econometrically
the the game to be two-team game the
solution is easy every player that
belongs
in one team will have the will share the
same utility with the co-members of the
team now if you want to have a two team
zero sum games those utilities will sum
up to zero
there are lots of different
different applications i will stay in
the second one because he was that my
co-author and my advising in the ua
really liked that
one example is actually the
you know all this ready the
wall street
short
and bidding that happened last year with
gamestop uh where you have two teams
that they are trying to collaborate but
at the same time they have their own
incentives
uh to play differently so that is the
reason that we really would like to
understand that kind of games so the
first question
is how hard is
to compute a nasa equilibrium in a team
zero sum game
the best answer that we had right now is
that they are cls hard and i put that
because approximating an epsilon nas
equilibrium in a conjugation game is a
cls
so
what i found even more interesting about
this kind of games is that
all of the classical uh discretization
that we know like gradient descent
optimistic grading scene extra grading
optimistic multiplicative updates
everything that we know they actually
cycle around in
in that phenomenon so in order to solve
that solution we would propose a new
method
it is a new method of discretization
that actually was proposed by people
that they are doing feedback control
theory uh
it is
actually we found out that
there were there is a similar washout
filter with the discretization scheme
that we did that is used in uh aviation
uh for the dutch roll movement
uh
so yeah
this is the method but i don't want
really to
to be more tiring than
what i am right now so we achieved to
show some sufficient solutions but we
strongly believe that there is something
more interesting in that kind of
feedback control discretization that has
not been
yet
utilized by the optimization people and
i would be really interested in looking
at that
in general this is my perspective in
this is my research and agenda i would
like to to be member of that kind of
world where i'm trying to create theory
about uh
the real machine learning i'm trying to
not create theory that
does not
speak about what is happening in
practice and at the same times always
remember that
and just for a thinking
slide another problem that is a very
game theoretical problem that i am
trying to solve is the following problem
uh it belongs to the tragedy of commons
interpretation so i'm trying to solve
the reading group assignment i want to
incentivize the simon's participants
with a mechanism without money to
present some interesting work in our
equilibrium and computational reading
group every tuesday 11 to
i always make a mistake about the nun if
it is am or pm but you got my point
you're really invited to to come
thank you very much
[Applause]
what we can really prove is actually
that if you give us uh the potential and
you can put it
in you if i have the potential of
yeah i have to clarify that we have not
achieved to find the membership of the
problem we will have only the hardness
of the of the problem so yeah i should
thank you for the question so the only
thing that we can say is that
if you give me a potential gain
and then i can put the the potential
function in the utility i can create a
dummy reception the reduction i can
create a dummy
team game and
the result
it is
a the result of the team zero something
will give me the epsilon
mixed number
of that problem but uh i i was trying to
ask also you what we can show about the
to understand a little bit the
membership
of that kind of problem yeah
thank you for the question
so guys
actually different asymptotics about
that
uh so
in that case what is the the meaningful
equilibrium this is a very good question
the reason that we tried we decided to
track nash equilibria is that for all
the other cases there are actually
results that they say that they are
interactable under some complexity sense
so that is the reason that first of all
i said okay let's look on that
of course always there is like the min
max where i will look only one
the preparation one thing but i thought
that this is an unfair situation i i try
to to be like
fair in both of the
two teams and understand an equilibrium
that would be uh referred to that um
yeah there is a an interesting question
that also we're trying to
address a little bit with iran is even
if there is no dual gun
in that case
if i come
structurally and
i have the only assumption that there is
no god
can we prove that at that case we will
discover nash equilibria this is not
clear in comparison with the classical
two-player zero-sum game but it would be
interesting to
discuss about that and see what is
happening
thank you very much